[Music]
welcome everyone
thank you for joining us today for the
apogee hybrid webinar
a quick introduction today we're going
to be speaking about
the apogee hybrid launch which we
launched a few weeks ago at
next in beta and today nandan who is
a product manager in google cloud and
he's the one who worked on it the most
is going to be
diving into all the details doing a demo
and speaking about
how apogee hybrid fits into the broader
apogee offerings that we have feel free
to submit
questions at any point in time you can
submit them right away
and we will try to answer them
throughout the presentation as well as
we have some time
set aside at the end to answer those
questions uh my name is shikha i
am a product marketing manager with
google cloud and i'll be the host for
today
and i'm going to turn it over to nothing
now thank you thank you
so much so let me give you guys a quick
overview of today's agenda
i'll very briefly talk about the apigee
api platform
what are the capabilities available and
then talk about
uh what are the hybrid use cases that we
have seen with customers so far and what
we
have in our current offerings and then
talk about the new offering that we have
and how it is different
from the current hybrid offering that we
have then we'll talk about some use
cases what we've seen with customers
and some guidance on when to use which
type of
gateway so with that let's start a very
brief
introduction to the apigee api platform
i know to many of you you've seen these
slides so i won't spend too much time
on them but it's always good to start
with a quick foundation of where we are
and how this matches with our current
offering set
so apogee is a full life cycle api
management product and
obviously what is full lifecycle mean it
it goes back to the beginning
of what is an api lifecycle
any good api should start with api
design
and if you had asked me a couple of
years ago api design and i would have
always said open api specification
that's or swagger edit as it was known a
few years ago
would have been a great place to start
but as we're seeing today
apis come in other shapes and sizes
we're seeing a lot of
graphql being adopted by enterprises
we are also seeing grpc as a as a
popular form factor so
api design now more than open api spec
but
fundamentally the fact that you start
with the design
hasn't changed and then the natural
evolution of that
api is then you're going to developing
that api securing that api
and deploying it and it is really deploy
that we are going to talk more about
today where do you deploy it
uh what has changed in the form factor
of where do you deploy is what we are
going to talk today
the rest of the pieces of publish
monitor
analyze and monetize really hasn't
changed
but we'll briefly go over them as we
talk about deploying apis in multiple
platforms
so this is the slide that we have that
talks about how apogee
fits in into a typical enterprise your
enterprise has
many types of applications you're
probably building new applications with
microservices
you still carry a lot of legacy
applications and they're all not
necessarily moved
and you're also consuming apis built by
other vendors
from salesforce from workday from from
other sas
providers and at the end of it api
management is
super critical for the consumption there
because at the end of the day what you
want to do is take all these assets
these business assets that you have and
make them available
to your consumers so if i had to
succinctly put
what does api management provide it
manages the relationship between
providers and consumers providers of
apis
and consumers of apis from that
perspective
we've got three or four fundamental
building blocks
we've got the runtime we've got
monitoring analytics
and of course the developer ecosystem
so how do these impact from a hybrid
perspective or what
specifically does it change from a
hybrid perspective
let's focus first on the runtime from
the runtime perspective we had
three types of gateways available today
uh in the cloud as well as on premises
we had
the enterprise gateway for hybrid we had
microgateway and istio as the three
types of gateways that we had available
to customers
from a mediation perspective this is an
api provider trying to connect that api
to
different sets of systems the use cases
that we saw
were security transformation
orchestration
abuse prevention and of course
extensions
some of these features we introduced
recently take for example extensions
we announced extensions uh in second
quarter of last year
which provides developers with the
ability to connect to
cloud services like data loss prevention
to mask or obfuscate
the api content to connect to say google
pub sub as an integration to your
messaging
platform and now we have started adding
services
that are outside of gcp like with aws
and also salesforce so extensions
and the runtime assets are really
providing those tools
to the developer and improving the api
providers productivity
by giving them tools to build and
connect to different sets of apis
in the same vein security is also an
important
aspect of exposing apis you probably
want to do security mediation
because not all of your applications
talk the same security language
it's important to mediate between them
so from a provider's perspective
as you're building apis you also want to
be able to
monitor and analyze them and these are
typically
different personas that look at this the
persona of a production operator is
going to look at your fleetwide
set of apis and look at it how are all
my apis doing are they throwing errors
are they
measuring or keeping up to the latency
is it not too high and things like that
but as an api provider i don't care
about the fleetwide aspects
of my api program i really care about
apis that
i have developed and for me things that
are important is
which is a consumer that's consuming my
api
what type of client devices are they
connecting from
if i am upgrading my api who gets
impacted
and so on so different sets of personas
but these are also
critical from an api management
perspective that you have all this data
available to them
and last and perhaps most importantly
all of this is done to make the
consumers
highly productive you want consumers to
find a single catalog
of all the apis that they are eligible
to access
and once they can access them that they
can request access to it and you as a
provider can manage
who or which of your consumers can get
access to these apis how much of it can
they get
and so on so it really comes down to
this right
the catalog of the portal becomes that
key place where you manage that
relationship
of consumers coming in hopefully
self-service
that they can auto register come and see
the set of apis that they have
and you as a provider deciding how much
and whom you want to grant
access to and this follows the
fundamental of an api management
platform
so with this what really has changed
what we have seen is that enterprises
are in a flux of moving workloads
from their data centers to clouds and a
lot of times
it is lift and shift in some cases it's
also lift modernize and shift
right so what does that mean for
api management what it means for us is
that for our in our enterprises we see
that
apis are going to be in multiple places
uh some apis are going to be on cloud
and usually enterprises are picking more
than one cloud provider because
they don't want to put all their eggs in
one basket and they're going to be some
apis that are never going to live on
premises and on premises or data some
data center footprint
is going to be a reality for a lot of
these enterprises and that's not going
to change
either so apigee's current offering
which is primarily in twofold which is a
completely sas offering
or a completely on premises offering was
what customers had the ability to pick
from
now the completely saf offering of
course worked when you had your
workloads already moved to the cloud
or if they already remained in the data
center and
the cloud platform could route requests
either to one or more cloud providers
or to your data center for enterprises
that were kind of apprehensive about
shifting workloads to the cloud they had
the fully on-premises version
of apigee and that they could run it in
their data centers
so what really changed you know what is
what was missing
one concern that customers have
expressed with using a fully sas
offering
was latency imagine this use case where
your consumers and providers are in the
same cloud or data center
you really don't want to make a round
trip all the way to the cloud to come
back in
what you want is to have a gateway much
closer to you
from a security perspective some
enterprises have standards where certain
api
traffic cannot leave their private
networks
and again a cloud offering in that case
doesn't make sense because you
have your api call leave your network
so in both of these cases we would have
told customers that they could use
apigee's on-premises offering and keep
that traffic
private the problem with using a fully
on-premises version
of apigee is that now there's an
overhead that customers have to maintain
the ui the rbac or the sso for this
they have to maintain all of the
analytics that to maintain the portal
they have to maintain really the entire
stack and what really they were looking
for
was the ability to keep the gateways as
close to the apis as possible
and not necessarily take on the entire
infrastructure
so those are sort of the beginnings of
why this was needed
so with apigee had defined api
management
and we started this in 2015 and we'll
show you some examples of how we did
that
of defining hybrid api management as
being this
that there is an apigee managed control
plane that is hosted banned painting by
apigee in the cloud and then there's a
runtime plane
that is hosted managed maintained by
customers
on other cloud providers or in their own
data centers
and the runtime plane contacted the
control plane to receive
instructions so it can operate it what
this
decoupled architecture gave customers is
the ability to deploy
just the gateways as close to workloads
as possible
that way latency was no longer an issue
api
traffic never left your network and it
could stay local
and yet you didn't have the overhead of
taking
the entire infrastructure and making it
available
so what really is part of this
management plan so the management plan
typically includes the ui
it includes the rbac for who can do what
within the platform the ui can
optionally include the portal
and i say optionally because some
customers like to have custom portals
for various reasons and they should of
course continue to have that ability to
have custom portals
and of course the analytics i want to
have these gateways asynchronously send
analytics information back to the
control plane
where we can aggregate this and create
dashboards
so that is hybrid api management to have
a decoupled management and a runtime
plane
you'll notice that i interchangeably use
the word
management and control plane yes there
are some subtle differences
but for the purposes of this
conversation i will interchangeably use
those words a management plan or a
control plane
and then you have the runtime plane that
can be distributed
running wherever which is receiving
instructions from this
management plane so the apigee
had two offering or has two offerings
with a
for hybrid in 2015 we launched
a microgateway and microgateway was
specifically
addressing the need for an api gateway
for microservices
when enterprises started to build
microservices and these were the really
early days of microservices in 2015
they were looking for a very lightweight
gateway that could do
basic api protection as close to the
micro service as possible things like
api key verification
oauth verification quarter spike cadets
were all critically needed for the api
as close as possible
a more centralized gateway would have
mean that every one of your micro
services would have to go through the
centralized gateway and come back
incurring um a lot of latency to your
microservices so they really wanted a
lightweight
lightweight gateway there and
microgateway continues to be adopted by
our enterprises and last year we did a
presentation with
hp where we talked about how hp
modernized their micro services
using microgateway so microgateway
continues to fill that segment of use
cases
where it makes sense where you have a
where you're building micro services
and you need a gateway as close to it as
possible
last year google announced istio istio
is an open source platform that google
announced with
other partners like red hat ibm and now
there are many more people like f5
networks and so on
and istio provides a service mesh
management infrastructure or a service
mesh infrastructure
so istio is meant to manage your micro
services
it provides features that a service
operator or a micro service operator
would care for
things that you want built into your
infrastructure so you don't want
every service developer to think about
things like
mtls routing load balancing
fundamental aspects that not every
service developer should think about
so as is your service mesh started
becoming popular and we are seeing
enterprises adopt
istio istio provides a very interesting
capability
it adds as the notion of a sidecar to
every
service that you build and that's what
you see here as the proxy
now when you already have a sidecar
associated with it
api says oh this is a very interesting
use case to do api management as well
the sidecar already exists and the site
card is capable of enforcing policies
so what we did in 2018 was to extend the
capabilities of sdo
make it knowledgeable about apogee
policies such as same
api key verification oauth quota
spikeris and all that
and have the sidecar proxy implement it
or
enforce it so in 2018 we launched
another hybrid offering
for enterprises that have adopted istio
to manage their microservices
they now get an istio that is capable of
apigee api management policies
so what then changed we see that there
are an evolving set of use cases
that customers while they
microgateway and stu certainly fit a
certain set of use cases
customers really wanted the capabilities
of the
enterprise gateway available to them
where their apis are
without having to go full-fledged opdk
so i've got my apis in gcp i've got my
apis in azure and i've got some apis in
my data center
and i want to manage them the same way i
would do it
in the cloud so there were two
fundamental requirements that came up
the first is that i want to maintain my
api proxy bundle format so for those of
you who have been using apigee
you're familiar with the api proxy
bundle format and all the policies that
are capable with
that that you can do with it and you'll
know that microgateway it still cannot
do all the policies
that the edge gateway does the gateway
that you see in the cloud
or that you see in opdk so
they give you a limited set of policies
but our customers wanted
all the policies that cloud had to offer
available to them
as close to the apis as possible the
second
both microgateway and institute use a
yaml-based declaration
which means that you have a different
bundle format between cloud
and between your hybrid offerings and
really what they wanted was a
universal common method in which the
same bundle format
should work for cloud should work for
hybrid should work on-prem
and there should be no differences
between them and
in response to this evolving use cases
really what they were asking for
is the ability to take the enterprise
gateway that they have in the cloud that
is capable of all this doing the same
proxy bundles
creating all the policies that are
available including the programmability
aspect
of the edge gateway and have that
available
as hybrid and that's exactly what apigee
announced
at google next on the 9th of april
where we have now in beta apigee hybrid
so although apigee had two hybrid
offerings in terms of micro gateway and
istio
this is the apigee enterprise gateway
working in the hybrid mode fundamentally
or principally it works the same
as the other two gateways it still has
the notion of a centrally managed
control plane
managed by apigee so apigee would be
responsible for the ui
rbac analytics portal and so on
and customers would be responsible for
the enterprise gateway that is now
decoupled
from the control plane and they can
deploy the
enterprise gateway in their data centers
and other cloud providers
and so on there is an important
difference here
this enterprise gateway is available
to be deployed only on kubernetes now we
will discuss
as we go through the demo what
kubernetes flavors and what are the
requirements
are and we'll get into details there but
this is again a change
of how customers would consume apigee
software
our opdk version for example is
available on vms
hybrid is available on containers to be
run on
kubernetes so when we talk about
hybrid and that there is a runtime plane
obviously that includes a gateway and
this is the enterprise
gateway that you would deploy on your
premises or other cloud providers on
kubernetes
but what does this runtime plane really
contain what is it that
you as a customer are responsible to
manage and operate
assuming that apigee takes care of the
management plane that's where you define
the policies
that's where you create the api products
and so on what is it that
gets shipped to customers there are four
logical components that are shipped the
first is
the message processor this is the api
gateway for those of you who have used
opdk you would see the message processor
because that would be one of the
components
that you installed and those of you who
have been using our sas
product you wouldn't know this but
that's what we call our gateways inside
as a message processor
that's really the same gateway that we
run in the cloud
that you're now able to deploy on
premises
what this means is that all the proxy
bundles that you build on cloud or on
opdk are fully compatible with the
hybrid gateway
they don't need to be changed the second
piece that is shipped along
with the runtime plane is an agent that
is able to replicate
data between the management plane and
where your runtime plane is deployed so
let's take an example
you have a developer developer creates a
proxy in the
management plane and then deploys the
proxy to say the dev environment
now the agent is now listening to any
changes that have been happening to the
dev environment and now
notices that there's now a proxy
available in dev
will now make that proxy available to
the gateways that are running on
premises
or on cloud and that is the job of the
synchronizer
it has a certain set of credentials that
allows it to access only an environment
or in a set of environments that you
give it access to and is able to
pull information like target servers
proxy bundles
resource files things that you will
create artifacts that you create
in the management plane and have them
made available
to the gateways the third component is
cassandra again our opdk customers would
know that cassandra is a persistence
mechanism we use
and we continue with it cloud customers
will uh who are not familiar uh with
cassandra will
be pleased to know that this cassandra
is also
deployed on kubernetes so we get all the
benefits of kubernetes here we've taken
time to
build the operator model for this so you
can manage kubernetes
in an easier way than you would with if
you had
deployed them on vms and lastly
there's a component called mart which is
an admin server
that helps us manage certain entities
that are required by the runtime plan
the
marge service is responsible for
managing
entities such as api products api keys
access tokens cache kvm
these are all entities that are created
by the runtime
for the runtime and and mark allows us
to administer that
so overall these are the four components
that a customer is responsible for
and that they manage and obviously the
data that
is stored in cassandra never leaves the
customer's data center
and it is or i shouldn't say data center
it's your network because it could have
been in another cloud provider
but it's data that never leaves your
approved infrastructure
so what happens from a runtime
architecture
how do these get deployed what is the
architecture behind it
okay so let's look under the hood and
see
what actually gets shipped you'll notice
that there are a few more components
these are
supporting components and at the end of
this i'll talk to you a bit about the
philosophy of how we have
built the runtime architecture the first
thing
is that with apigee hybrid apigee ships
istio
now this is a version of histo that we
have built into hybrid
it's not you don't have to bring your
own sdo it's not a separate thing it's a
istio version that we ship
that we manage it's under the colors and
the reason we use
istio is because it solves a lot of
problems
that we need it solves the problem of
doing intelligent routing
load balancing tls termination and so on
so instead of us having to reinvent that
wheel we really love using
uh technology built by our sister
organization in csp
and we are using it as part of our
architecture
so what you're seeing here roughly each
gray box translates to a pod in
kubernetes
and of course the istio load balance is
the point of entry
into the runtime architecture the istio
load balancer is
load balancing request to the message
processors which again is another
stateless component
that is doing the proxying before the
call
actually goes to your service supporting
this infrastructure are a few components
like
synchronizer we talked about it it's the
agent that makes
uh proxy bundles and other resources
available to the gateway
cassandra is where all the runtime data
is stored
so the runtime data is as close to the
gateway as possible
so it eliminates any latency we also
talked about the admin server on mart
and that it is responsible for managing
certain artifacts that the runtime
relies on
cache kvm products and so on and now let
us talk a bit about
analytics how does analytics work so
shift along with hybrid is an agent that
collects
raw analytics data from each of the
gateways
and asynchronously sends them to the
cloud so
from your perspective as the api
producer
or an ops person you're still going to
use the same
apigee user interface as you always did
to get all the analytics that you're
used to as that you're accustomed to
you would not see any difference between
where the gateway is actually deployed
it so happens that some of these message
processors are deployed
outside of apigee but from your
perspective you get
common analytics and the way it happens
is through this agent that is able to
collect
raw analytics data and send it back to
the cloud
but a lot of our customers have asked if
they can also get
or if they can also tap into this raw
analytics information for their own data
housing and bi processing and this is
not possible
without you having to export data out of
apigee again
the agent is capable of sending raw
analytics information to more than one
destination one of those destinations
would of course be apogee
the second destination could be
something of your choice you could use
gcs
s3 whatever is your favorite data lake
it can be routed there and now you have
a copy of the raw analytic as well
so the overall architecture of what gets
deployed
are these components and it follows a
fundamental philosophy
of open failed or failed open what does
that mean
you'll notice that all the critical
pieces for the success of your api call
is all available at the infrastructure
that you manage
should you lose connectivity to the
cloud so that's two components
martin synchronizers that kind of tether
to the cloud
are not able to tether to the cloud for
whatever network failure or
other problems that you may have all the
information that the gateway needs to
continue processing apis are already
available and you won't notice any
failures
yes it is true that you won't be able to
deploy a new proxy at that point
or create a new cache or a kvm but any
information that already made it through
before the failure
is already present and this is very
critical when running mission critical
applications on apigee that a constant
tether is not
necessary for your processing of apis
we actually have a few questions on the
architecture so why don't we take a
couple of them right now
one is is router and istio the same
so i presume the person who asked this
question um is familiar with opdk the
job of the router that we had in opdk is
now replaced by
istio's ingress gateway yes okay
but it does more than what the router
did so it of course
does what the router did and now it does
a lot more and
my following slides will explain what
the additional features
are okay uh does cassandra and runtime
architecture used
is it used only for caching or is it
also temporary storage for analytics
before they are pushed to the cloud
sandra is not used for analytics so
cassandra is used for the following use
cases
api products are there access tokens api
keys
cache kvm are the entities that are
stored in cassandra
nothing else is stored there and this
data that i'm talking about which is
again cache kvm access tokens keys
products and
all that is only stored in cassandra
there is no copy of that maintained
in the cloud so this data is is only
persisted in the customer's cassandra
okay is there tls between all the
runtime components
deployed in my data center yes all
components have
tls or mtls your option at least one way
tls is mandatory
2atls is up to you okay let's move on
and we'll come back to the rest of the
questions at the end
all right so what actually gets deployed
and
how are they deployed on kubernetes like
i said
the runtime architecture depends on
kubernetes it is not available
on a non-kubernetes platform and the
reason for that is we don't want to
reinvent a lot of the goodness that
kubernetes brings with respect to
upgrades
auto scaling and things like that were
already built into the platform and no
point in us trying to reinvent
that wheel so most of the applications
that we deliver are stateless including
the synchronizer which is replicating
data you blow on
and you bring up another it's going to
pull the data again so
effectively it is stateless but the
important thing that is stateful is
cassandra
cassandra is a stateful set and part of
the architecture relies on at least
kubernetes 1.10 or higher
so if you're on a lower version of
kubernetes you may want to think about
creating a new cluster
that is at least 1.10 or higher now of
course you'll get
more benefits when you go into some of
the higher versions but this is the
minimum version
that we are targeting now we have taken
some
important steps here to make the
operations of these components
much easier right so of course they all
use the
horizontal part auto scaler the
stateless components
and when you are dealing with a stateful
component like cassandra we are building
automated backup and these automated
backup primarily work
when you're running in other clouds like
gcp aws or azure because they provide us
with some capabilities that we can rely
on to exist
and so you as a production operator can
configure these automatic
backup tasks so we can take backup of
cassandra
and store it into say s3 or gcs
depending on
on where you're running so these are the
architectural details of how we are
deploying this on kubernetes
again if there are questions we can come
back to it at a later point in time
all right what we're going to do now is
we're going to
do a demo because i talked to you a bit
about the architecture
it makes sense now for you to sort of
see it see the demo in action
and then we'll come back to some slides
and i'll walk you through some more
architectural bits and they'll start to
make sense once you see the
demonstration
right and that may also give you the
opportunity to ask other questions
based on using the demo which will and
those questions will come towards the
end
okay so let's let's start with the demo
okay
um let me quickly walk you through the
setup that i have
i've got two clusters here and of course
i'm using gke here
i've got one cluster apigee and that
already has everything configured
everything is set up but i'm not that's
not the demo i want to show you
the demo i want to show you is the
cluster that i've got which is webinar
and you'll notice here when i click on
workloads all the things that i've
created are on the apigee cluster
the webinar cluster is completely empty
right the and what i want to show you
today is
first how did i set up this cluster what
are some of the best practices when you
set up clusters
and then going from 0 to 60 i've all i
have is an empty cluster
and i want to get hybrid going how quick
is that
what does it mean for me right so we'll
take a minute to spend about
what what is it that i have done to my
apigee to my gke cluster
so on this webinar cluster you'll notice
that i've got
two node pools i've got a node pool for
the runtime which i've got
three nodes for and i've got one
separate node tools for
the data for my stateful set which is
cassandra
usually what we would recommend is that
your stateful set has
a high speed data so either a local
storage class or a local with ssd
would be ideal from a performance
perspective
your runtime which is stateless it can
be its own
uh note pool and you know obviously they
can scale
independently of each other
all right is this better cool
um you'll also notice that i've got
something interesting going here with
respect to
uh leveraging secrets and encrypting
them
with hybrid and we'll go into this uh
into some more detail i've got a slide
on this
a lot of the application secrets like
encryption keys uh your northbound tls
certificates
and so on can are leveraging kubernetes
secrets
and when you leverage kubernetes secrets
on platforms such as gke
you could use something like an hsm or
kms as the repository for where these
are stored
and these are then made available to
this so anybody in um
industries where they're highly
regulated the
ability to store such sensitive data on
an hsm
will be very useful so i turned this on
so you can see
how that works so very very briefly
that's what i've got i've got a single
node
or a single region thrusters and i'm
going to set up
apigee on this the hybrid on this
the second piece i want to bring up is
that there is a yaml file that you
specify
where you where you specify the details
of what you what is it that you want
installed on this cluster
because while you have these four
components they don't necessarily
all have to go into the same cluster you
could move your stateful sets to one
cluster your stateless
components to another cluster and so on
given that flexibility you need some
sort of a configuration file
to know where goes what so
here is a yaml file that i've got which
is which we call the overrides.cml
and i've specified in it certain details
about for example what is the
credentials i need to pull the images
the docker images
first we sign all our docker images and
they're made available in docker hub so
you can configure your cluster
to trust images that are only signed by
us second you specify things like what
certificates to use for my runtime what
certificates to use for cassandra
whether you want mtls or tls these are
all things
that you specify in this overrides file
now a lot of these details i have
explicitly said
not all of them are needed if you're
doing a very simple poc type installed
you can skip a lot of these details
and we assume some defaults which are
not always acceptable
for a production deployment so i've got
this
overrides.yaml where i've specified for
each component
what it is that i want what happens next
now i'm going to switch to my terminal
and i'm going to walk you through what
happens next apigee has shipped
a utility called apigee cuttle
right uh kind of sticking with the theme
of cube cuddle and distilled cuttle
there's now apogee cuttle that helps you
manage
the deployments to the kubernetes
cluster
now i know some enterprises will use
helm some will use customize some will
use a whole bunch of other tools to
manage it and therefore this is
an optional tool it is a tool that
can help you at least initially to
understand
how we generate the kubernetes manifests
so i use
apigee cutter and pass the
overrides.yaml
this allows me to create a kubernetes
manifest
now if i run apigee cuttle with a dry
run
setting then it will only generate the
kubernetes manifest and not actually
deploy it
you can at this point customize it
change it make other things to it and
maintain your own set of kubernetes
manifest
that you can deploy later and if you go
into the folder
beta you'll notice that we use the go
templating which is kind of
what other standards like helm
also use so it is very similar from that
perspective
of what we have followed but because not
every enterprise will have help
nor should we assume that everybody has
help this utility
is handy to get you started
what i've done is i have in my
in my shell script written a couple of
lines of code
that set up the namespace create the
docker and then create run this command
to apply the override.tml
on my cluster so that is what i'm going
to do now i'm going to hit
setup and this is going to do it and
what we're going to do at the bottom
is start to watch what happens and
you'll notice
below that all these pods are getting
created
and we're going to give it about a
minute for this to finish
right and in the meanwhile while we wait
for this
clusters to set up let's take a few
questions the whole setup takes about
three four minutes ish give or take and
at that point we should
um we'll go back and now i'll walk you
through what i'm going to do next which
is to actually test it
right so all i did was create a cluster
a completely empty cluster i had nothing
else on it
i had a yaml file where i declared what
is it i wanted installed on my cluster
how many replicas and so on
then i run ran my command and now i'm
going to let kubernetes do its thing
of setting this up okay okay shikha some
questions
yep i actually see a bunch of questions
on the kubernetes piece and i think
one theme is can runtime be deployed on
anthos
gk on-prem aws eks
yes the answer to all of them is a yes
uh in fact on anthus there is a
slide that is going to come up of how we
integrate with answers specifically
and that should cover gke on prem um but
eks aks all supported yes okay
great can you run the containerized
runtime environment on
other container orchestration
environments like ecs
yes uh ecs is a no uh same for cloud
foundry
is a no at the moment they have to be
kubernetes based
okay great are you replacing micro
gateway with this new runtime
no i think microgateway fills a use case
that uh for microservices
that the enterprise gateway doesn't and
that will continue
in fact i see microgateway working in
conjunction
with the enterprise gateway uh where for
your micro services you continue to use
this and for other services
you could use the uh the enterprise
gateway
there are also a few different questions
around existing customers who are either
using opdk or
the staff solution can you talk in
general about
how someone who's using opdk today could
try out hybrid and how that would work
and similarly for the sas version right
so
to try out uh the product you know of
course please contact your
account rep and then we can work with
the account rep to sort of provision
an arc you'll notice that in the in the
documentation and i'll
show you the documentation in a minute
which talks about all the prereqs that
are needed and one of the prereqs
is that you need a hybrid enabled arm
to be created in the cloud and once you
have that
once that org is created then
you can try out hybrid
and is that i think there's a question
about where the orgs are if they can be
on private cloud or if they can be on
public cloud given that the management
plane is always adequately managed
your odd will always be created in the
cloud by apigee
and once you have that hybrid enabled or
you can try hybrid
okay okay so it took me about roughly
two or three minutes
to have uh the setup completed um you'll
notice very quickly here
we've got cassandra and then we've got
some jobs that create the cassandra
key spaces the users and so on uh we've
got
logging and i'll come to that in a in a
minute i've got my
synchronizer pieces running i also have
my message processor here
it's called mt and that's running all my
pieces are
more or less good to go and and running
so at this point
let me see if i've gotten a public ip
address
um and once i have my public ip
available
i should be able to try this right so
let's go to cluster
and let's go to webinar and let's wait
for this
all right so i've got my public ip also
available
so this is the ip address that because
i'm running on the cloud i can use
the service type as load balancer and it
automatically creates a load balancer
for me
if you're running this on premises then
you would use a
node node port mechanism and then you
would have something like an f5 load
balancer in front
of it and that would act as the inbound
ip address to your message processors so
at this point i'm going to copy this but
before i
actually run something i'm going to show
you a couple of things okay
hybrid demo one okay let me go to
api proxies here and i had a sample
proxy
deployed right this is the hello world
that comes with every r and this is what
i had deployed and you'll notice here
that the pods are asynchronously
sending deployment status back to the
control plane so when i deploy something
they asynchronously communicate
did that deployment complete now i'll
take a minute after
i show you my kill command what actually
happens here
with respect to deployments so bear with
me let's quickly try it
i've got a sample um
sample proxy there so i'm going to hit
curve and i'm going to oops i didn't
copy it so let's go copy this
here and v0
hello minus okay because i use a sales
line cert
and i got hello guest back right so my
proxies already got deployed
right so now let's see what actually
happened and how does this
change how does your developer float
change right
in this org i've got a bunch of api
proxies deployed
i'm going to deploy one now so i can
show you what
actually happens right and then we'll
switch to the analytics view
and see what happens there all right and
i'm going to actually deploy this
api proxy to this other cluster that i
have
deployments are now asynchronous right
it's really you're submitting a request
for deployments because the gateways are
no longer attached to the control plane
what you've effectively done this
is submit a job to say deploy this and
now the synchronizer which is listening
to these events
will eventually it pulls every 60
seconds that's the
full interval i set up and so within 60
seconds it's going to listen to this
change
make it available to the gateway and
then communicate that response all the
way back
at which point i will know that the api
proxy
was deployed so we'll give this another
30 40 seconds
to see uh the deployment went through
but we'll come back to this page
in a second let's look at a few other
components
with hybrid have taken some important
changes to the architecture oh there you
go it reported
uh it reported that uh the deployment
was successful you'll notice that the
uh that the change was asynchronous all
right that's good that was something i
wanted to show you guys of how
deployment deployments work which is
going to be different from how you
typically did this
okay let's quickly take a look at some
important changes
that we have done from an architectural
perspective right
if you look at the workloads you'll
notice that we are shipping
a few other pieces which we which are
new components that are shipped as part
of apigee let's pick the webinar
cluster right um here
we have a few components called
metrics and then we have logger right
so with metrics apogee ships prometheus
and prometheus is important for two
reasons
first prometheus becomes a relay point
from where
we push all the analytics to
stackdriver metrics now stackdriver
metrics will be
offered as part of apigee
or apigee hybrid so it's not a separate
thing that you have to go
get but it will be included as part of
apigee
monitoring so you get basic alerting
monitoring
all those things that you would have
needed to manage your runtime are
included with this
stackdriver automatically gives us these
capabilities
and those are included in the platform
the second piece is that we include the
apigee logger which automatically sends
logs
to stackdriver again all the logs from
your gateways from your
cassandra and everything else
automatically goes to stackdriver
where you get a robust
logging search mechanism
that is already shipped as part of the
product
having said that these may not
necessarily be your enterprise standards
and if you had an enterprise standard to
say app dynamics new relic or something
else
then by all means you should be able to
configure those as well
because we use prometheus as our relay
system you could
use prometheus as a point from where new
relic
or app dynamics or something else picks
it up from there
because we use something like fluency to
ship data back to stackdriver
that could be the point where you also
add a stanza and ship logs
to other platforms as well so while
apigee will certainly be
opinionated and provide these dashboards
through
a google gcp centric view of
stackdriver logging in metrics you're
free to configure
other platforms as well
what happens with environments and
load balancing and routing and this is
part of the reason why we introduce
something like
hto with hybrid we want to stop
environments as more as an sdlc platform
where you have a dev
a qa a test and so on you have to start
thinking of environments
as sandboxes right uh why is that well
we've shrunk the size of a message
processor so it can be containerized and
you can run multiple
parts in the same worker node in
kubernetes
second we've made environments
self-serviceable so you can create as
many environments as you want
so the environments have now become
sandboxes so create many environments if
you're doing
if you're running production create
fraud one product
three plot four and so on many
environments and each
environment has sandbox which contains
proxies of similar workload so now you
don't have a noisy neighbor situation
one proxy gets massive amount of traffic
other proxies are not being auto scaled
as a result it's only that proxy that is
now in the previous model the challenge
with having many environments means that
your virtual host
is also many and that's a terrible user
experience you don't want to have
product api.com
product2.api.com and so on but with the
load balancing that we're doing with
this dio
we are now able to make it intelligent
enough where the load balancer is able
to send that request to the appropriate
environment
right so although you have many
environments
they will have the same domain name or
the same virtual host
to which they access their apis so you
get your isolation you get the scaling
that you need
while not having to reveal some of these
infrastructure details to your consumer
a question i get asked a lot is hey i'm
not using history as my ingress i'm
using something else
what happens well first off to be
pedantic
istio doesn't use the ingress notation
it uses a gateway notation so
it's not really an ingress from that
perspective but
feel free to add something else on top
of the istio ingress
like an f5 load balancer or something
else but
the istio ingress is a part of the
apigee install we control it and we need
that to be
there to be able to do some of this
intelligent self-balancing that we do
too the tls certs and keys that are used
for the ingress they're all stored in
kubernetes secrets
so that's not information that that even
comes to the control plane
now we talked a bit about secrets
management secrets
are used in a number of instances
we use secrets to store encryption keys
for your encrypted kvm
we also use encryption keys for to
encrypt your cache
all of these secrets can are now in the
kubernetes secret
and in the example i showed with gke
i use nhsm to store my encryption key
also your tls secrets are stored there
and if you're using kubernetes 1.13
all the information in nct is also
encrypted
how would multi-region expansion work
well
most of these components are stateless
the only stateful thing is cassandra and
you would expand this by creating
additional clusters and creating a
ring that expands multiple regions all
right
so now we've got three options right
we've got microkey we've got the hd
adapter and we've got hybrid
what option is right for you so first
off let's understand what features
are there in the apigee platform and
what's available in hybrid
it is apogee's goal to make apigee
hybrid
feature equivalent to cloud it shouldn't
matter who manages your runtime apigee
or our customers
all the features that you get in the
cloud you should get
with hybrid some of these examples like
bot detection or hosted targets are
currently not available
in our on-premises version only
available in cloud
but with hybrid all of these features
will eventually be available with hybrid
as well so with that here's a quick
summary and i'm not going to dwell too
much into this
it will make available these slides
through the webinar so
you will have access to this information
but i'm going to quickly go through
because we're running out of time here
let me very quickly give you some
guidance on what you think when
right the first question you need to ask
is do you want sas or hybrid which is
you really want to manage anything at
all or you want to let man apogee manage
all the infrastructure if hybrid is the
answer
then the next question becomes well what
are you trying to manage the apis for
are they found micro services or are
they for a mix of old and new
right so if it is just micro services
then you could use either micro gateway
or sdo
if you're using istio and then that
becomes your choice of gateway
if your policies are going to be more
complicated than that
where you want to have all the advanced
features of the apigee edge platform
then apigee hybrid would be the right
answer for you
so this is a very very high level view i
i'm positive that
when you actually get into individual
customer scenarios
there'll be more questions than this i'm
going to take
30 seconds to talk about anthos and how
we run with anthos
anthos ships with gke eventually with
csm
and cloud run apigee would be works on
top of
gke on prem and eventually we'll be
looking for integration with csm
and other parts of anthos as well so
immediately we are we definitely support
gke and gke on prem
that's our integration with anthos and
over a period of time we will support
other features as they become ga csm is
not ga yet
so cloud services management which is
managed istio when it becomes ga
we will start integration with it as
well so with that
i'm going to pause down and go back to
shikha
okay great as you know we've run out of
time for questions so here's what we'll
do you can email your questions
which is apogee google.com feel free to
email questions there
also if you want to try out apogee
hybrid and beta feel free to send an
email there
what we will do is we'll take all of
these questions there's some great
questions
we'll make sure that our docs team has
access to those and they
will try their best to incorporate that
into the documentation
and feel free to post on the community i
think there's some questions on the
community as well we'll go through and
answer those there
and with that thank you so much for
joining us today and
for asking some great questions thank
you
[Music]